what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich so much
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with clinton marinova pompliano
p do not forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block that has
three products you can buy itself crypto
on crypto exchange
you can go and deposit crypto take out a
usd alone and get your crypto collateral
or you can earn up to eight point six
percent
apy in an interest-bearing account let's
go big dogs get a block fire account go
to block fight.com
pomp i think when you scream you make
the thingy go
oh shoot we forgot the microphone no we
don't even know microphones don't worry
i got a lot to say today just
team me up give me the softball okay
well
first of all we have a few things but
first of all
guys due to a miscommunication at the
hair salon
and they cut my hair short it's not a
miscommunication
spoke spanish you spoke english in
bulgaria and it's incompatible
bulgarian did not help me so i i love it
you look gorgeous i like the hair it's
almost as short as mine let's
okay okay bitcoin
is at a tipping point and could become
currency of choice for global trade
city says in a new research note
the cryptocurrency is at the tipping
point of mainstream acceptance or
speculative implosion the bank
added what do you think duh
duh bitcoin's eating the world you know
why bitcoins either
because it is the most superior store of
value and
currency to use on a global basis
nobody controls it nobody can create
more it's more efficient settlement
and it's cheaper faster than anything
else in the world
bang bang what's up so all i have to say
is all of these bears are going to be
crying
in tears until they capitulate speaking
of a
bear who capitulated shark tanks kevin
o'leary
you may know him as mr wonderful who
once told him
that bitcoin and crypto is garbage
pure garbage
now kevin o'leary is here to say
that bitcoin is here to stay and he
invested two percent of his portfolio
into
bitcoin into bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies we'll get rid of the
other things you know whatever
but listen kevin and i have actually got
to know each other he's a fantastic but
i've seen this friendship blossom over
the last few months and it is
hilarious we actually went to dinner
together once
in uh in miami and he wore a tax the
rich sweatshirt it was hysterical
uh but him and i we get along we really
like each other i think that if he's
called mr wonderful
i should be called mr right because he's
been wrong i've been right
he calls him the pomposaurus he calls me
the pomposaurus and i just call him
kevin he's like you know he's like the
old uncle that's a little crazy but it
eventually comes around to what the
young kids are thinking
but listen kevin he already knows three
percent's gonna become five five's gonna
become ten ten is gonna become fifty
kevin o'leary mr wonderful is only gonna
end up listening to mr
right mr right mr right now mr right
forever
don't worry kevin o'leary is now a
bitcoiner i worked my
ass off to get him there but he is now
in let's roll
michael sailor from micro strategy keeps
shoveling
getting the fiat and shoveling it into
bitcoin what is he doing
another one of my friends who is amazing
and very smart mr michael saylor
he gets it he is simply saying you're
going to give me
fiat currency which is going to be
devalued over time the value is going to
degradate away and so i'm going to
convert that
into a currency that is growing at 200
per year and i'm going to take the
devaluing currency i'm gonna put it into
the revaluating
currency where the purchasing power is
increasing not decreasing and that is
bitcoin so mr sailor thank you so much
he is now the proud owner of 90 000
bitcoin there are many bitcoin like it
but his 90 000 or his
98 sell them and that was not a lion
king reference
um people have was a jar head reference
no i think it's something else i think
you
know i'm positive there are many rifles
like it but this one is mine i'm
positive the people in the comments said
another film
well the people might be smarter than me
but they're not better at movies i
thought it was
this is simba i have one like it no
no hold on no this is your kingdom there
are many like it
but this one is your simba everything
that the light touches will one day be
yours
oh shoot all right well that used to be
my favorite
i'm telling you ain't nobody beat me in
the movie trivia all right
people have spent more than die hard's a
christmas movie
people have spent more than 230 million
dollars buying and trading digital
collectibles of
nba highlights what do you what you know
about that
it's very i am so tan i don't i don't
know if i want to say what i really
what i really think about this all i
will say is that i have not bought any
nba top shots and i do have questions
about whether people
are going to say to themselves why do i
own this random layup from the third
quarter of the lebron game
on a wednesday afternoon uh that has no
historical significance
now if you get like let's say jordan you
know jordan over
elo everyone knows that if you're a
basketball fan which was a game-winning
shot
and ends up being like a historic
highlight everyone wants to own that
all right but i just don't understand
like why some of these random highlights
or
ended up uh becoming so valuable uh my
guess is that there's going to be this
massive influx there's going to be a ton
of interest
capital locked there right now it's
really hard to kind of uh withdraw it so
you just get actually a lot of
turnover and so eventually there's
probably some deflation in the prices of
some of the assets
some of the other assets will continue
to become really really valuable so my
best piece of advice is like just be
careful
learn educate yourself maybe try it out
as entertainment at first and then if
you eventually
become an expert at it then become a
full-time investor or a real investor
around it guys
this is the story that i want to talk
about it's called
anthony it's called the so the ceo of
eat
just the california food startup
responsible for bringing the world's
first lab-grown chicken to tables
is here to disrupt
the livestock farm industry
i don't understand how we're
gonna grow chicken in labs but
apparently we're growing chicken and
labs
and people are eating it stop i'm out of
focus now oh
we're gonna fix this problem we're gonna
fix it it's okay listen this is what i
gotta say
i'm gonna eat lab grown you should move
in unison
yeah if i'm going to eat lab-grown food
i'm going to eat ice cream or some
really unhealthy stuff taco bell we
tried to kill you you guys remember
but i'm not going to eat lab-grown
healthy food because it's probably not
healthy for you what do you think is
going on in the lab that is better than
what's going on in nature
i'm all natural that's who i am all my
natural
mr wright mr all natural and so if i'm
gonna eat chicken i'm gonna be real
chicken
y'all could go eat this lab grown stuff
y'all are worried about vaccines how you
know they put nothing in the chicken
okay um so today it's ask lunch funny
time hashtag
ask lm in the comments below
today today is moist apology day
oh yeah today we messed up by the way
youtube is suppressing moist
because i could not we the whole team
walked
could not find his comment even though
and now his current comment hold on his
current comment has 59 likes
yet it's not at the top of the comments
of youtube
anyway moist uh in case any of y'all
were wondering
he said he puts his pants on before his
socks
dressing or undressing socks are always
last right foot first and left foot what
do you think about that
all right that's fair i just want to
hear day 12. i saw a little in here
i'm a moist people have problems oh he
called us fools what happened is you
fools didn't find it
wow that's bold moist i'm looking at the
comment right now i'm honored and
humbled you missed my presents but you
did so incorrectly
i put hashtag voice gang in the comment
couldn't find it edit just saw the
pinned comment where
we said we're happy you're healthy happy
safe and alive
uh i'm relieved y'all found it i was
worried it was my mistake we all make
errors i won't hold this against y'all
y'all
can't lie though it hurt that you
thought i would abandon chip
so easy yo moist if you keep using
hashtag moist gang
in the comments we gonna find it don't
worry well everybody use it people are
very concerned about moist as well
listen i i have i have an important
thing to talk about uh in a second but
moist here's my question for you
is when you wake up in the morning what
do you do first
do you brush your teeth shower or go
take a poop i want to know
when you wake up in the morning what's
the first thing you do shower
poop or brush your teeth bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends